you know this is a a question where
weather has suddenly become the entire
ball game on NBC News over the weekend
believe it or not Chuck Todd actually
said that things could be trending for
Dan santis cold temperatures so the
question is always about turnout but
that adds a new element what are you
going to be watching for tomorrow night
in addition to the weather well but
that's the point here it almost is the
entire ball game turnout because the
smaller the turnout that's when weird
things happen here yes you know Rick
sorm didn't win in a large turnout you
know those sorts of things and Donald
Trump has benefited from Big turnouts he
really you know when we've had the
higher the turnout has been in general
election the better more Trump voters
have come so and is there a uh is there
a complacency issue that Trump has to
worry about so I you know this is a a
question where WEA is suddenly become
the entire ball game it should be a real
advantage to Ronda Sanz here's the guy
that has been building an organization
longer than any other campaign he's got
the governor on his side who's got a
built-in organization this is why you
build an organization is when the
weather drops unexpectedly are you going
to get your people out right so in
theory this is all actually I think
setting up really well right now for
Ronda santz all right I I don't know why
Chuck Todd would say that unless he
thinks it might be true and we know that
the santis has had the best organization
down there all 99 counties they've
they've put the strategy the whole
strategy was that if we do well in Iowa
it shows that Trump can be wounded and
then we can kind of move forward right
now everyone mainstream media and all of
your friends and every we have friends
here this weekend everyone's saying the
exact same thing to me everyone says the
same freaking thing I like Trump most
people say I voted for Trump I what you
know whatever I'm just kind of over it
the santis is the guy but I don't think
it can happen it doesn't seem like it
can happen the polls make it seem like
it's never going to happen so what the
santis needs tonight I don't know that
he necessarily needs to win I think a
wind would send a massive freaking
signal but if it's close enough it shows
oh there is some damage that could be
done there we thought there was a 50
point gap and we thought that the guy
doesn't even have to debate so that
that's really kind of where we're at
right now but but the other piece of
this of course is that what you need to
do when we get to the the national
election is you have to find new voters
right if we are to believe that the last
election was legit now Donald Trump says
it was not he believes it was stolen
which always makes you think well why
wouldn't they steal it from you again
and are you doing anything to stop that
as far as I know the answer to that is
no
but if we are to believe the last
election Biden got 81 million votes and
uh Donald Trump got 75 million okay so
you got to find some new voters are
there new people that are suddenly get
into Trump I don't know I just don't
know anyone are there people that have
kind of had it with Trump yeah the
santis on the other hand are there
people that are crossover people that
could vote for this guy there's a ton of
evidence that that actually is the case
because we know what's happened here in
Florida the amount of Democrats who are
now Republicans here in
Florida